this thanksgiving will be a whole lot
different for many valley families eight
news now reporter salah jeremiah spoke
to some families
and stores businesses about the changes
they're making this year
with cover numbers being on the rise
many people i've spoken to have told me
that they have done their shopping
ahead of time and are relying on
pre-made meals in order to avoid those
large crowds
on thanksgiving yuri martin is the
general manager
at marie calendars every year they make
sure they have everything ready for
thanksgiving to make things
easier and convenient for shoppers and
this year is no different
thanksgiving feasts are available all
you have to do is reheat
they have been taking orders since
october 60 to 70 a day
martin says people started picking up
their meals as early as
monday we have a tent set up outside
where you can come and purchase the pies
we also have a canopy it says fees
that's where you pick up the fees
inside the restaurant you'll be able to
pick up individual dinners to go
or platters family platters we've got a
lot of people that are cooking
thanksgiving dinner
maybe for the first time tomorrow you
can't go to grandma's house you can't go
to mom's house and so
it's neat to see i think a lot of folks
are experimenting brian watcher with the
retail association of nevada says to
keep people socially distanced
there are staff at entrances counting
customers coming
and going now if you still haven't done
your shopping yet the retail association
of nevada wants to remind everyone
to make a list ahead of time so that you
can make your shopping experience a lot
smoother
quicker and safer reporting sally
jaramillo 8 news now
to avoid the holiday rush retailers and
small businesses
in nevada remind people to support local
business
use curbside pickup if you can along
with delivery services those businesses
need your help
statewide restrictions include wearing a
mask if you attend small family
gatherings we asked on twitter
will you follow this safety measure this
holiday 41 percent
say yes 59 percent say no